Menschen die sich in Sicherheit bringen
ist wahrscheinlich die gefährlichste die
ist in der Ukraine gerade gibt überall
um uns herum bleichen teilweise mit den
Händen nach hinten gebunden wir sind im
trainingshop dem Ort der am Nachmittag
so heftig von russischen Raketen
getroffen wurde das exklusive Interview
von Paul ronsheimer mit selenski und
vital sind wir hier
in meiner Stadt
es ist nur das Böse was jetzt aus
Russland kommt die Einnahme von Liman
ist ein großer Sieg für die Ukraine das
ist schon sehr skurril also mit youtube
funktioniert hier die Anleitung für
diese deutsche Panzerabwehrwaffe mein
Name ist Frau ronsheimer ich berichte
als Kriegsreporter seit über 10 Jahren
aus der Ukraine also im letzten Jahr hat
die russische Armee Kiew eingekesselt
hat bin ich mit meinem Team als einer
der wenigen internationalen Reporter vor
Ort geblieben das ist das was wir im
vergangenen Jahr erlebt haben
so sieht der Krieg aus in der Ukraine
[Applaus]
hoher Besuch in der ukrainischen
Hauptstadt
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius trifft
ein Bild Kriegsreporter Paul ronsheimer
nutzt die Gelegenheit für ein Interview
meine abgehärtet haben
das erste Mal in überhaupt
ne Stress
ed aber wir wissen doch sowas ist
vergänglich dann freut sich in dem
Moment rüber weiß auch
morgen so sind sie da Überzeugung dass
die Ukraine den Krieg gewinnen kann Sam
Drücker oben drin das ist eine
schwierige Frage und wirklich ein Blick
in die Glaskugel die Ukraine kämpft
wahnsinnig tapfer sie hat am tolle
Soldaten ich weiß es nicht das sind das
sind wirklich jetzt äh Fragen die man
einfach nicht beantworten kann ich bin
sicher dass ihr das Zeug dazu hat das
hängt aber davon ab dass wir als Westen
wirklich zur Stange halten und weiter
weiter Kräften unterstützen das ist die
entscheidende Frage und ob es dann
Zurückeroberung der Gebiete im Osten
kommt oder weiter das ist jetzt nicht
die Frage der Stunde gilt der Satz noch
die Ukraine muss diesen Krieg gewinnen
ja natürlich
Bild breaking news
guten Morgen Herr meine Damen und Herren
auch wenn es kein guter Morgen ist was
lange befürchtet wurde ist jetzt
eingetreten Wladimir Putin der russische
Despot man kann es nicht mehr anders
sagen hat die Ukraine angegriffen die
Militäroperation hat begonnen
in der Nacht vom 23 auf den 24 februar
startet die von Wladimir Putin offiziell
so bezeichnete
spezialoperation in Wirklichkeit ist es
der Beginn eines brutalen Krieges
seit heute Nacht
ist Krieg aber natürlich nicht in diesem
Ausmaß was wir dort erleben das
offizielle russische Truppen auch
offizielle ukrainische treffen das ist
etwas was auch Europa seit Jahrzehnten
nicht gesehen hat mein Gefühl ist auch
wenn hier teilweise die Menschen ganz
normal heute morgen ja zur Arbeit
gegangen sind denn sie sind diesen Krieg
schon länger gewohnt hier wo ich stehe
in der aus Ukraine die Ukraine hat gegen
diese Truppen am Ende mittelfristig
langfristig keine Chance auch wenn Sie
jetzt ein Flugzeug abgeschlossen haben
wollen und man sieht den müssen was
passiert wenn Truppen reinkommen dann
kann es passieren dass es hier im ganzen
Land
Entschuldigung meine Emotionen aber das
zu erleben doch dass du vier Jahren hier
als Reporter als überkommt ich doch weil
ich viele Freunde habe hier in der
Ukraine die Angst vor mir Leben haben
das Ziel der Invasion die Einnahme der
Hauptstadt Kiel und Absetzung der
ukrainischen Regierung
ein Jahr später erinnert sich Paul
ronsheimer an diese ersten Tage des
Krieges ich fand mir war nicht klar dass
die Russen wirklich Kiew angreifen
würden aber dass sie
angreifen würden weil mir klar das
völlig verrückte war dass mein Kollege
Vadim eine Gruppe aufgemacht hat bei
WhatsApp und die hieß war in Kiew Krieg
in Kiew und das war der Vorbote dessen
14 Tage vorher was dann passieren würde
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte wappnen
sich seit mehreren Monaten beobachten
sie russische Truppenbewegungen an der
Ostgrenze
passieren dass wir Krieg ausbricht und
die sollte sich dann verteidigen
wenn man sich das angeschaut hat habe
ich gedacht um Gottes Willen wie sollen
die sich gegen die russischen Panzer
verteidigen können hier die üben mit
Holz gewähren das ist ja alles nur noch
lächerlich
wenn man mit Holo domesilensky unterwegs
ist dann spürt man zum einen die
Anspannung wir waren heute an der Front
mit ihm heute Morgen hat es da
Einschläge gegeben und sie Lenski hat
gesagt zu mir nein ich will da jetzt hin
und ich will zeigen dass ich nicht den
Panik bin dass ich bereit bin hier zu
stehen und auch für mein Land ein Risiko
einzugehen
er war fest der Überzeugung des Kiew
nicht angegriffen wird
silensky hatte sich getäuscht wie viele
ausländische Experten auf die Russen
beschießen die Hauptstadt mit Artillerie
und Raketen Truppen fallen in die
Vororte ein mittendrin Paul ronsheimer
als einer der wenigen verbliebenen
Reporter
ich habe versucht dieses Gefühl beiseite
zu schieben als es losgehen weil ich
mich auf meine Arbeit konzentrieren
musste es gab eine Situation wo war diem
mein ukrainischer Kollege fast panisch
das Hotel verlassen wollte direkt zum
Bahnhof weil er Angst hatte dass die
Russen uns ein Kesseln würden dann ist
aber doch zurückgekommen mit Sack und
Park und hat gesagt nein ich bleibe für
mich war immer klar dass ich in Kiel
bleiben würde weil es hier in N war noch
da BBC war noch da und ich habe mir
gesagt den Ausländern wird schon nichts
passieren wenn die Russen an der Tür
klopfen
[Musik]
unser Kollege Paul ronsheimer der konnte
vor wenigen Minuten mit einer Frau
namens ihrer sprechen und gemeinsam mit
ihren drei Kindern hart auch sie in
einen dieser U-Bahn-Schächte unter Kiew
Ausland eingefallen hier tobt ein Krieg
Kinder sterben Frauen alte Menschen und
unsere Männer verteidigen jetzt unser
Land
die Politiker andere Länder
schütteln Putin immer wieder die Hand
und vergessen dabei dass das ein Mörder
ist
[Musik]
der schon acht Jahre lang kaltblütig
Krieg führt
aber heute
hat er alle Grenzen überschritten
wir haben Irina nachts in der Metro
getroffen mit diesem protestschild
Stopp Putin das war auch schon eine
Situation wo die ganze Zeit Sirenen
waren und Kiew eben andere Tech also da
unter Beschuss stand und dann am
nächsten Tag haben wir die Nachricht
bekommen dass eben sie getroffen wurde
ins Gesicht und ihr Gesicht völlig
entstellt wurde
es ist unklar ob es ein Unfall war oder
ob am Ende ist möglicherweise eine ein
direkter Angriff war weil sie dort eben
mit gegen Putin
demonstriert hat davon gehen die meisten
Beobachter hin nicht aus dennoch eine
dramatische Situation und man sieht
daran dass es hier sehr wohl Zivilisten
trifft und eben nicht nur wie gesagt
wird das ukrainische Militär
jetzt gibt es ein bisschen Hoffnung um
Irina denn sie hat es mit
internationalen Hilfe und diesem
Flugzeug raus geschafft aus dem
Kriegsland aus der kriegshauptstadt Kiel
sie ist am Abend gelandet in Düsseldorf
Bilder der Hoffnung dort unterstützt von
Notärzten die Bundespolizei hat geholfen
und sie wird jetzt sie sehen sich hier
auf der Trage beim JA Transportern in
den Rettungswagen sie wird jetzt
versorgt
intensivmedizinisch in der Essener
Uniklinik alles Gute an ihr
heute geht es ihr besser sie ist in
Deutschland sie wurde operiert ihr
Gesicht zumindest teilweise wieder
hergestellt so weit es möglich war
und ich glaube sie ist vor allem
glücklich dass sie überlebt hat
[Musik]
das Leben der Ukrainer verlagert sich
immer mehr unter die Erde um den
russischen Angriffen nicht schutzlos
ausgesetzt zu sein auch Krankenhäuser
evakuieren die überirdischen Stockwerke
dieser Krieg hatte zugeführt dass die
Menschen dann wenn das Alarm gibt hier
unten in den Keller flucht man sieht
hier die Rohre die hier verlaufen und
die Patienten sind untergebracht in
diesem Zimmer sowas
sieht man wie Patienten warten und wir
sehen kleine Babys die hier sind kleine
Babys untergebracht in diesem Bunker
es war völlig surreal dort in diese
Geburtenstation zu gehen wir sind dann
in den Keller also den Schutz Keller
sozusagen dieser Station wo dann
dutzende Babys lagen und geschrien haben
und
Eltern die dort waren gleichzeitig diese
Reden draußen es war vielleicht zu der
erste Moment wo man wirklich gedacht hat
um Gottes Willen was passiert jetzt hier
ja und was wäre wenn eine Bombe diese
Geburts Geburtenstation treffen können
heute alleine heute sind sechs Babys
geboren worden ein neues Leben
in einer
Situation die
schwer zu beschreiben ist weil es für
die Menschen hier so schwierig ist wenn
wir uns den Krieg anschauen und was
draußen auf den Straßen los ist
[Musik]
der Moment im Krankenhaus ging mir auch
deshalb nach weil ich dort mein
Fotografen Jürgens gesehen habe der
selbst Vater geworden ist kurz bevor er
hier mit mir in die Ukraine gefahren ist
und ähm er ist weggefahren als seine
Tochter eine Woche alt war und sie ist
mittlerweile ja fünf Wochen alt und er
sagte zu mir was in das wie sehen das
bewegt hat weil er hat das Baby ist zur
Welt gekommen in einer sicheren
Situation in Athen und in einer Lage wo
eine normale Klinik hatte aber nicht so
einen Keller
ist mit seinem Team wieder in der
Ukraine unterwegs diesmal ganz im Osten
bei bachmut wo es besonders gefährlich
ist
ich versuche meine Familie und meine
Freunde dann immer zu beruhigen was
nicht so leicht ist weil ich glaube
durch das Live Reporting und die Bilder
die natürlich kommen
haben sie natürlich noch größere
Emotionen als wenn ich jetzt etwas
schreibe oder es Berichte ja ich glaube
das ist noch mal was völlig anderes und
versuche dann zu sagen dass wir
natürlich immer versuchen in Sicherheit
zu sein aber jedem ist ja klar dass das
Risiko für die Kollegen dort gerade am
Anfang immens war
wir sind jetzt hier im Checkpoint von
dem ist Richtung wachmut geht man hört
schon dass Donnergrollen in der
Artillerie hier und auch die Soldaten
sind ziemlich ernst die Lage ist unklar
vor allem die Frage wie lange die Stadt
zu halten sein kann die Soldaten sagen
uns die nächsten Tage die nächste Woche
könnte entscheidend sein
wachmut ist die derzeit am heftigsten
umkämpfte statt in der Ostukraine jeden
Tag hagelt es hier Raketen und Granaten
die meisten Einwohner sind geflogen
einige wenige verkaufen Gas und
Lebensmittel auf dem Markt einer der
Männer hat einen Raketenangriff nur
knapp
drei Raketen sind in meinem Laden
eingeschlagen ich stand nur gut ein
Meter entfernt nach dem Schlag habe ich
mich auf den Boden geschmissen eine
weitere ist im Hof eingeschlagen direkt
neben der Garage
Richtung Osten fährt also Richtung
Konstantin auf der bachmut ist das Leben
teilweise völlig zum Erliegen gekommen
man schläft dort in Privathäusern da
gibt es teilweise auch keine Hotels mehr
oder man ist direkt an der Front da gibt
es noch weniger Strom kein Internet man
benutzt Generatoren
wir haben gerade Informationen bekommen
das ist eine Großangriff geben soll ein
weiteren in ungefähr einer Stunde
deswegen versuchen wir jetzt die Stadt
so schnell wie möglich zu verlassen
es ist unfassbar wie man hier noch leben
kann denn jederzeit schlägt überall hier
etwas ein
waschen lernen
das war ziemlich knapp gerade also der
Motor ist wohl nur 200 300 m von uns
entfernt eingeschlagen das zeigt wie
hier wirklich alles jederzeit in der
Stadt einschlagen kann und ich verstehe
gar nicht wie man als Zivilist hier
länger als wenige Stunden aushalten kann
das ist schon kaum auszuhalten
im März 22 sind Raketen Angriffe auch in
der Hauptstadt an der Tagesordnung
wieder eine Hochhaus beschossen in Kiew
zwei tote mindestens 9 verletzte
mittendrin parnsheimer unser Bild
Reporter mit den klitschkurs jetzt genau
dort Paul
hier ist ein weiterer Ort beschossen
worden wir sehen hier ein völlig
zerstörten Bus mitten in der Stadt
zusammen mit Wladimir und vital sind wir
hier sind wir das sehen Vitali hier wenn
wir wenn wir hier diesen Krater sehen
dann sieht man ja was was hier sozusagen
passiert insgesamt in der Stadt richtig
kämpfen gegen Nationalisten Faschisten
extrem dicke die schlagen nur an
militärwirten das ist eine Militär
das ist eine ein Lächeln sie sehen das
ist eine Form
bekam gegen zivilen Menschen in meiner
Stadt die beiden Klitschko Brüder kenne
ich sehr sehr lange wir sind
freundschaftlich auch verbunden weil wir
uns eben seit zehn Jahren kennen aber
das erste Treffen war völlig anders als
in den Wochen Monaten Jahren zuvor denn
ich habe sie schwer bewaffnet gesehen
mit Schutzweste mit mehreren Bodyguards
und um sie herum die Sorge die Angst in
Nervosität auch in ihren Gesichtern
Schlaflosigkeit das war etwas was dann
mein Blick noch mal sehr verändert hat
Kiews Bürgermeister der xbox-weltmeister
Vitali Klitschko wächst in seinem
schwersten Kampf über sich hinaus
gestern mit meiner kleinen gesprochen
mit kleinste
er ist schon nicht mehr kleiner
weil 17 aber wenig Zeit sogar sogar mit
mit Kinder zu sprechen und alle haben
schicken mir SMS aber pass auf hier
Papa pass auf Dich auf sagen die Kinder
von Vitali Klitschko in diesen Tagen und
damit
gebe ich zurück nach Berlin vielen Dank
ich war sehr berührt von diesem Moment
als Vitali Klitschko dann über seinen
Sohn gesprochen hat weil er eigentlich
eher selten über seine Kinder und seine
Familie redet und er dann darüber
gesprochen hat wie Sie schreiben und das
war in dem Moment so ein Gefühl
der Sohn ja die Kinder haben Angst um
ihren Papa der hier im Sturm steht um
den einmal Russland zu verhindern und
ich weiß noch dass meine Stimme da im
Live Interview wirklich gebrochen ist
weil dass du das Gefühl war um Gottes
Willen ja was passiert hier und wird
Vitali das überleben weil das war etwas
wo ich auch nicht sicher war und mir
klar war er wird's überleben ich glaube
wenn draußen diese Stadt eingenommen
hätten hier dann hätte es wahrscheinlich
nicht überlebt
und alles gut
okay
ja dann machen wir schnell eine drüben
oder ja
Klitschko empfängt das Team in seinem
Büro in der Kirche Innenstadt das Leben
in der Hauptstadt läuft inzwischen
weitgehend normal weiter verglichen mit
der schwierigen Situation im Osten des
Landes
wie schätzt du den Frontverlauf momentan
ein gibt es eine russische Offensive
wird die noch kommen was ist deine
Analyse die berufsun versuchen aber ist
ohne Erfolg die schicken tausende von
Menschen die die
schmeißen die beste seine Einheiten aber
trotzdem ohne Erfolg siehst du eine
Gefahr für Kiel für den nächsten Wochen
ich hoffe der Russen kommen nicht nach
gif aber Gefahr ist immer da und müssen
wir
voll bereit sein und ich schließe nicht
aus der Russen versuchen noch einmal
eine Kiste oben weil Kiefers ist
Hauptstadt eine Herz des Landes
[Musik]
die Situation in der Ostukraine spitzt
sich weiter zu ich bin in ihren adfk
einer Stadt in der Nähe von Donalds dort
wo die russischen Truppen rein wollen wo
schon einige sind und Ludmilla hier
hinter mir sie hat sich gerade in Ihren
Keller geflüchtet das ist wie ein Bunker
für Sie denn es gab wieder heftigen
Artillerie Beschuss hier direkt an Ihrem
Haus die Front die verläuft sozusagen
quer vor dem Grundstück auf der einen
Seite die ukrainischen Soldaten auf der
anderen Seite Separatisten
[Musik]
hier in der Ostukraine sind die meisten
Häuser zerstört oder stark beschädigt
Ludmilla ist eine der wenigen
BewohnerInnen die nicht geflohen sind
mit ihren Tieren lebt sie aus Angst vor
dem Bombardement fast ausschließlich im
Keller jetzt ist es wirklich dramatisch
die Häuser drumherum sind alle
beschädigt Ludmilla sagt die Einschläge
sind fünf bis sechs Mal am Tag so heftig
dass sie sich um ihre Tiere klammert und
hinter den Möbeln versteckt aber dennoch
sie will weiter nicht weg obwohl hier
Kampfflugzeuge fliegen obwohl Grad
obwohl Artillerie eingesetzt wird und
obwohl fast alles um sie herum in dieser
Straße zerstört ist sagt sie ich will
hier nicht weg ich will in der bleiben
[Musik]
der Reporter kehrt nach einem Jahr
zurück Ludmilla lebt allerdings nicht
mehr in ihrem alten Haus
danke schön
Ludmilla zeigt dem Team die Schäden an
ihrem alten Haus sie konnte dort nicht
mehr bleiben
ich musste zu Hause weggehen denn zu
Hause überleben war unmöglich es war
sehr schwerer Beschuss pro Sekunde fünf
Schüsse ich bin dann für zwei Tage zu
meinen Verwandten gegangen war also
nicht zu Hause als ich zurückkam sah ich
dass mein Haus von einer Granate
getroffen war
das Haus war zerstört Ludmila hat
innerhalb von 20 Minuten das wichtigste
gepackt und ist in ein anderes Haus
umgezogen
[Musik]
seit 18 Tagen ist Krieg seit 18 Tagen
berichten wir darüber mit unseren
Reportern im Krieg mittendrin weil wir
zeigen wollen und zeigen müssen was
Putins Angriff bedeutet für die Menschen
für die ganze Welt und auch er hat genau
das tun wollen zeigen was ist unser
Journalisten Kollege brennt Renault US
Regisseur Fotojournalist unter anderem
für die New York Times heute war Brand
zur falschen Zeit am falschen Ort in
erpin bei KF 8 km vor der
kriegshauptstadt haben ihn heute Schüsse
getroffen tödlich getroffen
in irpin dem wohl am heftigsten
beschossenen Vorort von Kiew eröffnen
die Russen an diesem Tag das Feuer auf
US-Journalisten
wie heißt du Juan woher kommst du aus
den USA und bist du okay ein bisschen
schwindelig aber mein Freund ist
getroffen und dort zurückgeblieben
sein Kollege der amerikanische
Journalist Brent Reno bleibt vermisst
offenbar schwer getroffen durch
russischen Beschuss
sein Kollege Juan arrondo kann sich
ebenfalls angeschossen retten und wird
wenig später ins Krankenhaus gebracht
sie waren zusammen an der Front
unterwegs
wir waren jenseits der Brücke in irpin
und haben Flüchtlinge gefilmt die das
Gebiet gerade verließen uns hat jemand
angeboten und im Auto mitzunehmen dann
sind wir an einem Checkpoint
vorbeigekommen und dann fing sie an auf
uns zu schießen also drehte der phara um
aber sie haben immer weiter geschossen
mein Freund Renault wurde getroffen und
es dort zurückgeblieben
gegeben sowohl heute als auch gestern
von russischer Seite das ist das was die
Ukraine uns berichten das ist schwer
sozusagen einzuordnen in dem Moment aber
tatsächlich ist es offenbar so dass ist
weitere Verletzte und möglicherweise
Tote gab bei diesem Vorfall und wir
jetzt recherchieren müssen was dort
genau passiert ist tatsache ist dass wir
auch von weitem Leben Scharfschützen
immer wieder
Artillerie Feuer gehört haben ebenfalls
in ihre PIN also die Kämpfe dort
bekämpfte in der in dem Vorort von dir
die gehen unverändert hat
[Musik]
Brand Renault wird schließlich tot
aufgefunden
ihr wurde 50 Jahre alt
es gibt Berichte wonach ukrainische
Soldaten angeblich die beiden gewarnt
haben sollen nicht weiter zu gehen das
ist aber wie gesagt noch unbestätigt es
ist immer eine Abwägungsfrage gehe ich
diesen einen Schritt noch weiter gehe
ich noch ein Checkpoint weiter versuche
ich noch weiter zu kommen das muss man
als Journalist immer selbst entscheiden
nicht nur für sich selbst sondern für
das ganze Team und das ist durchaus eine
große Verantwortung ich bin
großer Trauer für den Kollegen für seine
Familie und mit großen Respekt vor allem
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die diesen
Krieg zeigen die zeigen was den Menschen
passiert und ich glaube wenn ich das
persönlich sagen darf ich versuche da
nicht zu viel drüber nachzudenken denn
ich glaube das hält man gar nicht aus
ich glaube die Gefahr erkennt man immer
als hinterher man versucht natürlich ein
Risiko einzuschätzen und ich glaube wir
das Team Jorgos war die und ich haben
das immer gemeinsam entschieden aber
natürlich wenn man dann erlebt wie der
Kollege an einem der Verletzte an einem
vorbeigetragen wird die Leiche
des Kollegen Brand Renault dann merkt
man wie unmittelbar man immer mit dem
Tod bedroht ist und wie sehr man
aufpassen muss jedes Mal wenn man dort
ist und wie sehr es doch auch Zufall ist
ob es den Kollegen oder dich trifft
[Musik]
sieben Monate verbrachte ronsheimer
allein letztes Jahr in der Ukraine seine
Wohnung in Berlin überließ er
ukrainischen Flüchtlingen zum Aufräumen
seines Büros kommt er selten und das
hier sind meine drei eine der drei
Lieblingsbilder das ist das erste Bild
des Interviews du siehst hier die ganzen
Sandsäcke das war Anfang März also
wenige Tage nach dem ersten Angriff auf
Kiew das sind schon so Momente die einem
bleiben ja also es war das erste
deutsche Interview mit silence Gewehr
des Krieges live damals bei Bild TV und
dieser Moment dort zu sitzen neben der
Person über die damals die ganze Welt
gesprochen hat und jeder dieses
Interview natürlich wollte
das schöne Erinnerung die bleibt und
auch die Anspannung die man hier auch
auf diesem Bild sieht finde ich also mit
den ähm mit den Sandsäcken und auch sein
Gesicht ja ich glaube ich konnte deshalb
so Ex Bild berichten weil ich in den
Jahren vorher sehr viel schon in der
Ukraine war also es hat jetzt wenig
damit zu tun dass man gedacht hätte
Mensch der ist besonders proukainisch
oder was auch immer sondern er die
Tatsache dass ich würde mir selenski
schon vorher kannte er auch ein gewisses
Vertrauen glaube ich damals zu mir hatte
und natürlich Bild als Marke ich meine
wir erreichen eben Millionen Menschen
einerseits durch die Zeitung durch
online durch den TV-Sender und das
natürlich schon etwas was dann am Ende
auch attraktiv ist für jeden Politiker
vor wenigen Minuten hatte Paul
rornsheimer unser Mann vor Ort dort die
Gelegenheit mit dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski an einem geheimen
Ort zu sprechen er wollte unter anderem
wissen wie groß ist seine Angst von
Putins Killerkommandos getötet zu werden
wir hören rein in das Interview ein
bisschen Präsident
Report herr Präsident es gibt Berichte
von der wagnergruppe die sie töten
wollen und das Vladimir Putin sie töten
will ich als Präsident dieses Landes
habe kein Recht Angst zu haben und meine
Seele schmerzt auch und ich mache mir
Sorgen um meine Verwandten und wir haben
Angst unser Leben und den Ort wo wir
leben zu verlieren ich habe Angst mir
vorzustellen dass ich kein Land mehr
habe
das Video vom Handschlag mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten geht damals auf
Twitter viral
es gab Millionen Klicks auf dieses Video
von The lanski wo er den Handschlag mag
vor allem auf das was er gesagt hat weil
ich ihn gefragt habe wie es ihm geht und
er relativ relaxt dann gesagt hat ja
einem gut
sowas in der Art und wo alle gesagt
haben wow wie kann dieser Mann ja in
diesen schweren Stunden noch so
entspannt wirken und das war glaube ich
dieses Interesse ähm was dieses Video
ausgelöst hat wir haben einen Krieg
Russland gegen die Ukraine es sind so
viele Menschen jetzt gefallen das Land
wurde zerstört was könnte schlimmeres
passieren für die Menschen die ihre
Kinder verloren haben wir glauben an die
Zukunft wir werden nicht aufgeben wir
werden unser Land nicht verkaufen
[Musik]
der wahre Wert des Lebens ist das Leben
selbst und dass du nicht ermordet wirst
und das muss Europa tun das einfache
Leben verteidigen und auch die wahren
Werte auf den ersten Platz stellen und
ich wünsche ihnen dass ihre Priorität im
Leben die wahren Werte bleiben aber das
was jetzt bei uns passiert das könnte
auch Ihnen passieren
das ist mir ganz besonders wichtig wir
sterben auch für Sie
man bekommt sehr viel mit von den
Menschen selensky vor und nach einem
Interview weil man sich immer noch
unterhält er macht immer noch Späße ja
selbst im März hat er Witze gemacht ja
über Russland über Putin ähm er hat
immer gefragt wie ich die Situation in
Deutschland einschätze er wollte von mir
häufig wissen wie ich bestimmte
Politiker einschätze weil das ihm das
größte Kopfzerbrechen bereitet hat
also selensky hat von Anfang an nicht
verstanden warum Deutschland so lange
gebraucht hat um Hilfe zu liefern
[Musik]
er hält ronsheimer großen Respekt Preise
und viel Aufmerksamkeit von
verschiedenen Seiten
[Musik]
die Rolle im Blickpunkt zu stehen davon
bekommt man in der Ukraine erstmal gar
nichts mit und ich war ja monatelang
dort und habe einfach berichtet das war
dann anders als ich das erste Mal nach
Deutschland wieder kamen nach vier fünf
Monaten
und mich viele Leute angesprochen haben
auf unsere Ukraine Berichterstattung
viele haben sich bedankt
erstaunlicherweise habe ich kaum
negatives mitbekommen auf der Straße
oder wenn ich in dem Restaurant war
anders als es jetzt in den sozialen
Medien war wo man ja merkt dass
sozusagen die Leute die gegenwaffen
Lieferungen sind sehr vehement auch
unterwegs sind und einen kritisieren was
ja auch völlig in Ordnung ist aber
teilweise eben auch beschimpfen aber in
der realen Welt habe ich das nie
mitbekommen
wir sind auf dem Weg nach Butcher der
Ort ist weltbekannt geworden weil
russische Soldaten dort Zivilisten
dutzende Zivilisten hingerichtet haben
wir waren einer der ersten Journalisten
vor Ort und haben die Leichen in den
Straßen gesehen und eine Frau die mich
am meisten bewegt hat dort war Irina
denn als wir sie interviewt haben lag
die Leiche ihres Mannes noch vor ihrem
Haus und heute wollen wir von ihr wissen
wie sie mit ihrem Schicksal umgeht und
wie sie weiterhin gut erleben kann
es ist der dritte april ein kalter
verregneter Sonntag ein Tag an dem sich
der Welt das Grauen von Putins blutigem
Krieg gnadenlos offenbart das Massaker
von Butcher mitten in der Hölle trifft
Paul ronsheimer Irena vor ihrem Haus nur
wenige Tage zuvor muss sie mit ansehen
wie ihr Mann Oleg von russischen
Soldaten misshandelt und ermordet wird
ich wurde beiseite geschoben und sah wie
unser Haus in Flammen stand Oleg wollte
den Brand löschen aber sie haben ihn
nicht gelassen sie haben ihn auf die
Straße gebracht er musste sich hinknien
dann haben sie ihm in den Kopf
geschossen
olex Leiche liegt zu diesem Zeitpunkt
noch immer vor dem Haus Nachbarn
bedecken den Leichnam provisorisch mit
Plastikplanen
immer wieder bricht sie in Tränen aus
blickt auf das von den russischen
Soldaten völlig zerstörte Haus
[Musik]
zurück bei Bild live an diesem
Sonntagnachmittag ich weiß es gibt
gerade gemütlicheres und Angenehmeres
als die Bilder von Kriegsverbrechen und
doch müssen wir Ihnen diese Bilder jetzt
genau jetzt zumuten in diese Bilder aus
Butcher bei Kiew die haben noch mal eine
neue Dimension
Butcher der Vorort Kiews wird als
grausamer Wendepunkt in die Geschichte
dieses Krieges eingehen mehr Brutalität
und Menschenverachtung kann ein Ort kaum
ausstrahlen als die Straße auf der
dutzende unschuldige Zivilisten gefunden
werden
das was wir hier sehen
zeigt die ganze Grausamkeit mit der die
russische Armee hier vorgegangen ist wir
sind mit den klitschkurs in Butcher
diesen Vorort und überall um uns herum
laichen teilweise mit den Händen nach
hinten gebunden
der Bürgermeister sagt es sind unzählige
Menschen hier umgebracht worden
Zivilisten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein knappes Jahr später ist Butcher von
den Russen befreit das Leid aber ist
nicht weg irina hat nicht nur ihren Mann
verloren auch ihr Haus praktisch die
gesamtes Hab und Gut sie lebt jetzt bei
Nachbarn und zeigt Paul Ronzheimer wo
früher ihr zu Hause war
[Musik]
jede Nacht auf sehe das gleiche Bild ich
gehe aus dem Haus sehe auf der Straße
wie mein Mann getötet wird
dieses Bild wiederholt sich immer wieder
und sehe Leichen auf der Straße das ist
das Bild dass ich immer sehe
naja
was würdest du wollen dass die Welt über
deinen Mann erfährt wie er so war
Krieg ist furchtbar er nimmt uns die
geliebten Menschen mein Ehemann war
meine größte Stütze im Leben
niemand sorgt sich jetzt um mich er war
der beste Ehemann der Welt dann kamen
die Russen und haben mir alles
weggenommen
das Schicksal von Irina und ihrem
Ehemann sie teilt es mit tausenden
Ukrainern
[Musik]
es muss weitere Konsequenzen haben dann
wurden Menschen auf offener Straße
abgeschlachtet von der russischen Armee
zivile
s wenn das keine weiteren Konsequenzen
hat dann weiß ich auch nicht
[Musik]
das hier ist normalerweise ein
Sommercamp Haus wurde aber benutzt von
den russischen Soldaten in den
vergangenen Wochen die hier in Botschaft
gekämpft haben hier zu bleiben ist noch
eine Tee Kanne die hier steht und da
hinter mir sieht man Sandsäcke das sind
die Orte hier von denen die russischen
Soldaten man muss sagen ihre Horror
Taten verbracht haben von hier sind sie
ausgerückt und haben Zivilisten getötet
hier in Butcher mehrere hundert sagen
uns offizielle
[Musik]
hier haben russische Soldaten während
des Krieges um Butcher gewohnt und
hinter mir sieht man Dinge die offenbar
aus verschiedenen Häusern geklaut wurde
wo man versucht hat etwas Wertvolles zu
finden und hinter mir sieht man hier wie
das Haus geschützt wurde das Haus und wo
jetzt russische Soldaten und darunter
auch tschetschenische Kämpfer gewohnt
haben
von ukrainischen Quellen das esse ich
vor allem um kadirock-kämpfer handeln
soll also die aus Tschetschenien
gekommen sind und die auch schon vorher
als besonders Gewalttätigkeiten wir
gehen davon aus dass Botschaft nur der
Anfang gewesen ist wobei auch meine
Quellen sagen das ist dort eben
besonders heftig war aufgrund der
Konzentration dieser kadiro Truppen noch
einmal das ist das was die ukrainische
Seite sagt aber man muss davon ausgehen
dass das was ein Gutschein passiert ist
kein Zufall war oder die Tat von
verrückten Mördern sondern dass das Teil
der Militärstrategie ist
diese Straße in Butcher hat das
bestätigt was viele befürchtet hatten
schon Monate vorher nämlich das Russland
bewusst pro ukrainische Menschen
abschlachten würde massakrieren würde
Zivilisten hinrichten würde und ich
erinnere mich als ich durch diese Straße
von Butcher gelaufen bin und diese
Menschen gesehen habe einen mit
Kartoffelsack ein anderer der gerade mit
seinem Fahrrad dort lang gefahren ist
ganz klar zu sehen dass das eben
Zivilisten waren die nichts mit diesem
Krieg zu tun haben das hat bei mir noch
einmal die Sicht auf die Brutalität der
Russen völlig verändert
im Juni 22 ein besonders gefährliche
Einsatz des kriegsreporters in der
Ostukraine spitzt sich die Lage bei Lucy
chansk zu die Reise dorthin ist
schwierig es kompliziert und ist
wahnsinnig gefährlich denn es gibt nur
noch wenige Straßen die dorthin führen
man muss sich das so vorstellen die
Russen haben vor diesen Bereich komplett
einzukesseln also komplett
einzuschließen und dann die ukrainische
Armee dort stellen zu können zur Aufgabe
zu zwingen oder dort alle zu töten
[Musik]
und sein Team dachten sie hätten die
berüchtigte road to Hell relativ
unbehelligt passiert als sie etwas
später etwas unerwartet doch noch
Gewehrfeuer hören
gerade da unser Auto geschossen wurde
Straße ist wahrscheinlich die
gefährlichste hier ist in der Ukraine
gerade gibt
hinter mir das Fenster was von dem
erwischt worden ist
die Russen beschießen hier diesen Weg
weil das der einzige Weg raus ist aus
der Stadt
wir wussten dass wir auf dem Weg in
einen Ort waren der schwer unter
Beschuss stand wir wollten über die
Zivilisten dort berichten und haben es
dann wieder raus geschafft und auf der
Strecke wo wir waren da haben wir nicht
mit Beschuss gerechnet das heißt das
passierte dann plötzlich erst weiter von
uns entfernt eben Artillerie ungefähr
300 500 m und dann plötzlich direkt vor
uns der erste Einschlag der zweite der
dritte und dann das Ding was durchs
Fenster sozusagen gegen das Fenster zu
Bruch gegen und einmal über meinen Kopf
ich mich zum Glück geduckt hat hatte
weil ich mich in dem Moment erinnert
habe an einen französischen Kollegen der
einen Projektil hier direkt in den
Inhalt in die Halsschlagader bekommen
hat und dann gestorben ist
noch ein Video das viral geht die
Studentin Alina telefoniert gerade mit
einer Freundin als wenige Meter neben
ihr eine Rakete einschlägt Paul
Ronzheimer trifft die 17-jährige in Kiew
im berichtet hat den sie dort an dem
Morgen erlebt hat und der Alltag für so
viele Menschen hier geworden ist im
Alltag auch für uns ich gucke mich
gerade um weil gerade eben hat es hier
wieder äh Schüsse gegeben Luftverteilung
mitten in der Berichterstattung über
raketenschläge wird ronsheimer plötzlich
selbst Betroffener eines Angriffs
die neue Anschrift
ja es hat gerade zwei weitere Angriffe
hier genau an der Stelle gegeben an der
wir waren mit Kamikaze drohen wir haben
dann das Maschinengewehrfeuer gehört was
man auch in der Szene sieht gerade eben
mussten wir hier Schutz suchen an dieser
Stelle und dann erneut eine heftige
Explosion ein Einschlag ähm die
Druckwelle hier zu spüren die Menschen
haben sich hier auf den Boden gelegt um
sich zu schützen davor
und es ist immer wieder damit zu rechnen
sozusagen dass hier nicht weit entfernt
ist weitere Angriffe geht
wir gehen einmal in diese Richtung
weiter rein ich zeige euch das noch
einmal wir sehen hier Presse wir sind
dort eben den Hauptbahnhof
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay
ja ich habe eine erneute
erneuten
Angriff in diesem Moment offenbar und
das ist die Situation
wie es Menschen hier in Kiew geht
[Applaus]
noch einmal ist der Reporter an der
Ostfront Deutschland hat der Ukraine
gerade die Lieferung von Leopard zwei
Panzern zugesagt hier kämpfen sie noch
mit
älteren deutschen Haubitzen gegen die
Russen wir sind an einer ukrainischen
Position von wo aus mit der deutschen
panzerhaube zu russische Ziele
angegriffen werden was gleichzeitig
bedeutet dass diese Position von den
Russen immer wieder angegriffen wird die
Soldaten sagen uns das kann jederzeit
ein neuer Angriff passieren
[Musik]
eine etwas krude Mischung aus teils
veralteten Restbeständen und
selbstgebastelten Hightech hält hier die
Stellung am Leben die Ukraine ersehnen
dringend Nachschub von ihren Verbündeten
ich glaube nicht dass die Deutschen
Leopard alleine ein gamechanger sind
aber möglicherweise die größere
gemeinsame Anzahl also als Polen aus
Europa insgesamt also die Anzahl an
Panzern die geliefert werden ich glaube
das Russland bereit ist mit einer
Kriegswirtschaft so lange weiter zu
machen bis bestimmte Ziele erreicht
werden ich sehe überhaupt keinen
Widerstand gegen Putin ganz im Gegenteil
ist es noch viel ruhiger geworden und
deshalb darf sozusagen der Westen nicht
aufhören insbesondere Munition und Hilfe
zu liefern weil ansonsten sind die
Ukraine auf sich selbst verlassen
die Ukraine ist angewiesen auf ihre
Partner auf die USA auf Deutschland und
auf die Medien die Reporter
denn sie sorgen dafür dass der Krieg und
die Menschen in der Ukraine nicht aus
dem Blickpunkt der Welt geraten
[Musik]